federal agents again
firing tear gas at black lives matter
demonstrators in downtown portland
the protesters have spent weeks
demanding racial equality in america
while others are calling for police
reforms and an end to brutality by
officers
the city center courthouse is the focus
of the anger in portland
that anger increased when president
donald trump ordered federal agents to
be sent to the city to protect the court
18 arrests have been made this week
fireworks were aimed at the building and
several fires lit
federal agents responded with tear gas
i'm nervous i would like to not get shot
at
we just want to help people we're here
to
wash out eyes take care of people that's
it
oregon state officials opposed federal
law enforcement in portland
they say federal agents in riot gear are
only making the situation worse
we're looking at
the rebirth of this nation
[Music]
protests across the u.s began in may
after the police killing of unarmed
black american george floyd
trump has promised to back the police
and stop the protests
in a speech this week he said he will be
sending hundreds of federal troops to
cities all across america
americans must hold their city leaders
accountable
they must insist that community
officials fully support
fully back and fully fund their local
police departments
there is simply no substitute for a
police department
that has the strong backing of city
leaders as well as the tear gas fire
during the latest unrest in portland
peaceful protesters released balloons
and bubbles
more protests are expected leah harding
al jazeera